[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the
self-proclaimed greatest psychic of the
21st century the manipulative lying and
generally shady Reagan erotica from mob
cycle 100 when we first meet Reagan he
is the sort of mentor of our hero mob a
14 year old boy with amazing telekinetic
powers but we quickly learned that
Reagan is actually a con man someone
with no psychic or spiritual abilities
whatsoever and yet someone who also
happens to run a supernatural consulting
agency he basically takes money from
people based on completely fraudulent
claims that he has amazing psychic
powers and is an expert on supernatural
phenomena in reality Reagan has no
powers and whenever he needs to deal
with a real supernatural problem such as
exercising an evil spirit he has to rely
on his assistant mom we see Reagan
manipulating everyone around him on a
regular basis including his clients and
the media and Reagan also tends to take
mob for granted at times for example
calling him in to work on very short
notice and messing up all of mobs plans
in the process so let's face it at first
glance Reagan seems like a pretty
terrible person someone who lies
manipulates and scams gullible people
out of their money and with all of these
things in mind we might expect him to be
the villain of the series someone who
mob needs to kick to the curb in order
to become a better and more independent
person and yet Reagan is not a villain
in fact he is a beloved character and
many fans of mob psycho consider Reagan
to be their favorite character in the
entire series the thing is Reagan is so
popular that he even got his own manga
spin-off but how is this possible why
would anyone think that this sweaty
lying conman is someone we should
actually like support and root for the
reason is this
Reagan is not a one-dimensional
character he is a nuanced and complex
person and the fact that he is a conman
is only one aspect of his character if
you hate Reagan because he is a shady
con man and that is the entire extent of
take on the character you are only
scratching the surface of who Reagan
really is it's true that Reagan left his
job as a regular salary man to start a
supernatural consulting agency even
though he had no psychic powers of his
own at first he was basically a masseuse
he massaged his clients as part of what
he calls a spiritual cleansing and with
many clients this procedure actually
held them feel better this is because in
many cases the clients that came to
Reagan weren't really dealing with evil
spirits or curses the only thought that
they were so Reagan's spiritual
cleansing served as a placebo the
clients thinking that the evil spirit or
curse had been removed started to feel
better even though there were no spirits
or curses in the first place despite his
obvious shadiness Reagan is driven by
the desire to change the world for the
better to make a difference and this has
been his desire ever since he was a
student by starting his own business he
wanted to do more good than he could as
a regular salary man but he quickly
realized that he was just a glorified
masseuse and he was about to abandon his
agency until a young mob came to ask him
for help
mob heard about the agency and came to
Reagan because mob was struggling to
come to terms with his own psychic
abilities and believing that Reagan also
had the same type of power mob was
hoping that Reagan could help him
control them better at first Reagan
think that mob is just a troubled kid
with an overactive imagination
but he still feels bad for him however
Reagan soon realizes that mob really
does have psychic powers and so instead
of abandoning the agency Reagan decides
to use mobs incredible powers to deal
with real spirits and with other
supernatural threats despite the fact
that he started off as a con artist
Reagan isn't just a conman paradoxically
even though he is a fraud he is also a
man with principles a strong sense of
right and wrong and a desire to do good
and help others while using mob to deal
with all the real psychic threats Reagan
also helps his clients by giving them
advice on life and helping them avoid
getting tricked by other frauds like
fortune tellers on multiple occasions in
the story we also see that at his core
Reagan is a good person like when he
cancels on assignment to exercise a
family of harmless ghosts who just want
to live together in peace or when he
refuses to accept payment in cases where
he feels that it would be inappropriate
to take the money Reagan also makes mob
promised him not to use his powers
against other people or to use his power
with murderous intent and he does this
because he knows that if mob begins
using his powers for dubious ends mob
will no longer be the kind and good
person he is now and his power would
corrupt him it is clear that Reagan
genuinely cares about mob and his
feelings in episode 11 of season one we
see Reagan take a major risk when he
ventures into the headquarters of the
Esper terrorist organization known as
Klaw because he was concerned for mobs
well-being but let's be honest it is
clear that Reagan does have a tendency
to take mob for granted like when he
decides to call mob into work on short
notice because he just assumes that mob
has nothing better to do and that he has
no friends or anyone else in his life
who deserve his attention other than
Reagan this type of behavior leads mob
into thinking that Reagan might just be
using him for his power and this results
in a falling-out between the two of them
after they drift apart
Reagan ends up being humiliated on
national television and he is attacked
for being a fraud by the media in this
moment Reagan comes to realize how much
he depended on mob and how much mob has
grown as a person in the years that they
have known each other when mob sees
Reagan being humiliated at a press
conference he decides to help him and
uses his power to make it look like
Reagan is indeed an esper after this
Reagan and mob reconnect and this proves
that Reagan did indeed have a positive
impact on mob mob even says that he's
always known what Reagan really was from
the start and what Reagan really is is a
genuinely good person even though he is
far from a perfect mentor and even
though he sometimes takes mob for
granted Reagan wasn't just using mob the
two of them became friends along the way
and established a real connection
Reagan is truly an interesting and
complex character on the one hand he
most definitely is a sweaty conman who
manipulates people around him and even
though he has some positive traits like
being intelligent having a working
knowledge of martial arts and being a
pretty hilarious guy in general there is
also a deeper aspect to his character
whichever way you look at it Reagan is
far from the perfect mentor and far from
the perfect hero he is nowhere close to
the ideal role
for mob or for anyone else who happens
to be watching the anime but we love
Reagan precisely because he is far from
perfect he is not a traditional anime
mentor figure that we can look up to
someone like coming up from Gurren
Lagann Yami from black clover or all
might from MHA to name just a few
Reagan is not a role model he is not an
inspirational underdog but he is real
the shown and mentors and Shonen heroes
are the people we strive to be they are
role models who inspire us but Reagan is
just a deeply flawed guy in a suit who
makes lots of mistakes but who
nevertheless has important redeeming
qualities as human beings who are not
fictional characters we are all far from
perfect we all have our flaws but we
would also like to think that we have
our redeeming qualities we would like to
think that despite our imperfections our
insecurities in our mediocrity we could
still grow and develop into better
people
this is Reagan's story he starts out as
a regular salary man who dreams of doing
something more with his life he turns
into a conman but he is about to give up
that job until he meets mob and feels a
real sympathy for the young boy together
with mob he is able to deal with real
supernatural threats and really help
people even though he doesn't have any
powers himself nevertheless and Reagan
still makes mistakes he lies a lot about
being the greatest psychic in the
universe and he tends to manipulate the
people around him and to take them for
granted including mom but even as he
makes these mistakes
Reagan shows redeeming qualities such as
caring about mom's feelings worrying
about his safety genuinely wanting to
help others and recognizing that certain
things are far more important than money
and mob sees this - and even he believes
that Reagan is a genuinely good person
we love Reagan as a character precisely
because he is not the ideal role model
we love him precisely because he's just
a sweaty lying flawed character like the
rest of us we will never idolize Reagan
as some sort of inspirational figure but
we can relate to his flaws we can
recognize that he is just a human like
the rest of us and we can also relate to
his potential to develop and grow as a
person which is exactly what he has been
doing throughout the course of the
series
yes Reagan is a funny guy yes his
schemes are entertaining and yes his
obnoxious confidence as a sidekick
despite the fact that he has nothing to
be confident about is hilarious to watch
but that is not why we love him at his
core Reagan is just like us imperfect
and flawed but also kind caring and
determined to make a difference in the
world and if this sweaty lying conman
can learn to become a better person in
spite of all of his faults then so can
the rest of us and that is why we all
love Reagan if you enjoyed this video
you can leave a like to let me know and
if you're new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell feel free to check us
out on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar for all the latest anime means I
want to give a huge thank you to our
anime uproar patrons including our pro
hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh and Keylong we recently
completely revamped our patreon so if
you're interested in supporting more
content on this channel feel free to
check us out linked in the description
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]